Chloe I know that I'm already late
for you yes darling but I am ovulating
oh my God if I if I if you give us five
minutes to go
do something really fast
uh yeah Kourtney Kardashian press pause
on filming Hulu's the Kardashians so she
could get busy with her hubby Travis
Barker we're just living our best lives
it all went down on the season three
premiere when Court Sister Chloe came
over to hang can Travis do it in five
yeah he can I'll can I wait here you
wait here we'll be back I'm gonna leave
my microphone with you packed
and that are you really ovulating yes I
am you know how this story goes first
comes love then comes marriage Vegas was
like our Wild Rock Star wedding
let me try Santa Barbara was like as
traditional as like everybody else's
wedding could have been do we say
anything I thought
Italy was just really romantic and
classic
then comes baby the lovebirds have been
open about wanting to expand their
blended family Travis and I want to have
a baby and so my doctor took us down
this road of doing IVF and like it
hasn't been
the most amazing experience what has it
been like to be on the path to baby with
Travis it's a beautiful thing that we'd
love to have happen the journey is a bit
hard for any women who have been on it
and emotional of course Court shares
three children with her ex Scott Disick
13 year old mason 10 year old Penelope
and eight-year-old Reign while Travis
has two kids with his ex Shayna Moakler
19 year old Landon and 17 year old
Alabama
think just
being happy is most important and being
a good parent to my kids
we are just embracing that whatever's
meant to be will be yeah now Court says
they're trying to get pregnant the
old-fashioned way we are officially done
with IVF we would love a baby more than
anything but I just really believe in
what God has in store for us if that's a
baby then I believe that it will happen
and they're having a lot of fun in the
process I was laughing for the first
five minutes
so hard I was crying that's like sexy
because I couldn't deal on that I was
like get it together get it together
we'll just have to wait and see how all
that baby making business turns out but
in the meantime we're loving seeing
Court happy and thriving oh we all love
it this is her time to shine baby